incontournable de bruxelles l'atomium
construit en 1958 à l'occasion de
l'exposition universelle a dû fermer ses
portes au public pendant le confinement
depuis 15 jours il accueille à nouveau
des visiteurs ravis de pouvoir
contempler les monuments de la capitale
belge
seuls nous n'avons pas la tour eiffel
nous avons l'atomium et donc sa première
la première halte alors que l'on fait
maintenant voiture pour rentrer après
dans le centre-ville premiers rôles
comme ça on peut regarder le panorama de
bruxelles justement puisse y fait bon
donc on en profite mais le nombre
d'entrées est pour l'instant peu élevé
problème
l'atomium s'autofinance à 90% avec les
tickets vendus et sa fermeture a eu de
lourdes conséquences
trente mille euros perdus chaque jour
pendant deux mois et demi pour soutenir
l'édifice la direction a lancé un appel
aux citoyens belges
on a fait une projection et on s'est dit
que si on voulait s'en sortir cette
année si nous faudrait de l'ordre de 3
millions d'euros
voilà on fait appel au sirop dont les
jeunes
aux mécènes qui voudraient soutenir
notre édifice on dit aux bruxellois en
duo belge aux flamands wallons vie venez
visiter cet endroit et cet édifice
nationale pour faire en sorte que les
belges viennent visiter et ne se
contente pas juste de la voir de
l'extérieur
grand absent de cette réouverture les
touristes étrangers
pourtant indispensable à l'atomium
habituellement ils représentent deux
visiteurs sur trois depuis ce lundi les
frontières des pays voisins rouvrent
progressivement
l'occasion peut-être de les voir revenir
visiter l'un des monuments les plus
emblématiques de la capitale de l'europe